deliver Washington Post melting down
over a canceled culture Firestorm the
steward of democracy facing intense
backlash over their reaction to an
employee's retweeted joke on Monday the
post suspended reporter Dave wiegel for
a month without pay it's going to be
tough after he retweeted apologized for
then unretweeted a sexist joke we'll
show you the joke every girl is bi you
just have to figure out if it's polar or
sexual
one of Weigel's colleagues shared a
screenshot of the retweet and publicly
called him out for it on Twitter since
then it's been a woke Civil War at
Washington Post Greg you you're
delighted in this story it's the best
story ever I don't think you gave it
justice they are eating each other alive
they're calling each other out on
Twitter and this is what happens when
adults hand the reins to Children woke
adults are not real adults they're
humorless infantile boars who can't tell
the difference between real and imagined
misery Bezos should come in there and
just scream grow up but he won't he's
too busy hanging out with that new chick
this is the product this is the product
of the death of blue-collar Journalism
we've talked about this a lot of people
in The Newsroom didn't have college
degrees now they're over Diplomat right
and so they can't they you don't see
this kind of behavior on a factory line
or on a construction site but you see it
with these people that all they do is go
to class and complain and Report the
professors Guapo got suckered by people
who get attention on social media but a
journalist isn't striving to get to be
the object of attention they're looking
for objects to bring attention to it all
of these hires have been people that are
used to having people click click click
click click and so now they're eating
each other alive and the reason why
they're eating each other alive is you
can't field a unified team with everyone
who wants to be the center of attention
that's why we work so well here that's
why we all share we never do we never go
on Twitter and I don't make I don't say
I say everything into people's faces to
our face yes bash people on social media
ever ever
does seem like Fox we like each other
here not so much over there well
well I think that what Bezos should do
and maybe all Journal all news
organizations should do it but for the
all the people at the Washington Post
they should say
everyone's banned from Twitter for a
month everyone and then they can sort of
take it from there like let's get back
to doing work wire and that also do you
remember back in the day when the person
who was the snitch is the one who got
punished right yeah I long for those
dogs yeah stitches get stitches yeah
yeah like if I if if I said like in my
household if I had said Angie did this
my parents would have been like you need
to go mind your own business right what
happened to that I don't know we need to
bring shaming snitches back shiv right
we yeah we need to make examples out of
it
Tulsi
um Twisted priorities I mean the
Washington Post is supposedly about news
and journalism and facts they are more
concerned about cancel culture and you
know suspending without pay this guy for
a month for retweeting a comedian's joke
more concerned about that than they are
about people like Taylor Lorenz who
writes articles that are factually
inaccurate misinformation bias so on and
so forth I mean it it is a sign of the
times to show how far off track The
Washington Post has become more of a
propaganda organization than a news
organization how would you have handled
Weigel would you have suspended him
would you brought him into HR
in my office when people started
fighting with each other I said you
either get along or you both get out
okay you don't have time for this Petty
nonsense you got a job
not adults that's the problem was the
joke funny
you said in the break it was funny
because it's true
again oh that's right speaking of the
fastest is up next featuring a dance off
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now